simon klich enseigne les sciences au
secondaire il a 15 ans d'expérience et
près de 200 élèves de trois niveaux
différents
sa journée à l'école commence vers 7h45
habituellement il en ressort à 15h30
j'ai deux groupes deux premières cartes
groupe de deux secondes un groupe de
cinq secondes
il doit donc travailler chez lui en
moyenne trois heures par semaine selon
leur convention collective
les enseignants du primaire et du
secondaire doivent passer 27 heures avec
leurs élèves
il y a cinq autres heures de travail
personnel qu'il doit faire à l'école
pour un total de 32 heures pour biais
des enseignants comme simon klich les
cinq heures de travail personnel à
l'école ne sont pas suffisantes
c'est vraiment la planification surtout
que je fais à la maison mais ça se
résout à un corrections seront un
débordement qui est reconnu
implicitement a défait d'équité
salariale et d'assurance emploi
le gouvernement évalue la semaine
moyenne des enseignants à 40 heures
c'est sur cela que se base le ministre
de l'éducation
quand vous dites à les parents québec
les enseignants sont énumérés à 32
heures semaine c'est peut-être pas une
bonne chose parce que les enseignants
québec sont rainurés 40 heures semaine
la demande patronale ferait passer de 32
à 35 heures l'obligation d'être présent
à l'école dit han est pas question
c'est notre autonomie c'est une
reconnaissance
il se fait le travail prend deux heures
à l'école on le fait pas ce sort
laisse-moi planifiée laisse moi par mes
recherches
les syndicats craignent que les
directions d'école en profite pour leur
imposer encore plus de tâches assignées
quand nous manque de surveillants
corridas par exemple pas mal à et du
midi au lieu de faire une récupération
avec nos élèves mais je pense qu'on peut
prétendre qu'on travaille pour la
réussite des élèves professeurs
cette spécialiste en ressources humaines
comprend pourquoi les enseignants
s'accrochent à leur autonomie
professionnelle et/ou temps de travail
personnel du travail de préparation de
recherche
il faut toujours se tenir à jour dans
l'économie du savoir donc au fond la
frontière entre le travail et le hors
travail elle devient de plus en plus
difficiles à établir
avec toutes les compressions qui eut
pour vrai le avec des enfin je préparais
tous à gérer tout ça c'était plus un
enfer simon klich gardent la flamme de
l'enseignement mais il veut faire en
sorte que le temps qu'ils y consacrent à
la maison n'empiète pas trop sur sa vie
de famille ici anne louise des tati
radio canada montréal
oui